the last talk of this afternoon before
the panel it's chris harsher from yale
university the floor is yours thanks
thank you
thanks to the organizers of the workshop
uh it's been a great pleasure to be here
this is joint work with uh fred
frederick i have a little bit of feed
back here uh frederick who's here and
dan and paul
okay so before we begin before i give
any talk i like to tell people that i'm
a person who stutters
i feel more comfortable saying this i
hope you get more comfortable hearing it
this is focused on the presentation and
interpretation of mathematical results
rather than the techniques used to prove
them though those are also interesting
i'd love to talk about
we're going to formally define this but
i want to say up front that we're
working in the finite population
potential outcomes framework this is
different than the frameworks they're
usually talked about uh in the workshop
in the last workshop as well uh but but
pong did a great job talking about it uh
this mor this morning i will define it
all again here
so how should we randomize treatment
assignments in experiments so i've got
this group of people here i'm going to
put them into a treatment group and a
control group
so one option to put them into these two
groups is independent random assignment
so i could take a random half put them
in treatment a random half and i put
them into con took control
but
i may know more things about these
people i might measure
things like their hat type hat color and
pant type
these things are known before the
experiment is run so we call these
things covariates
now
one problem with this random assignment
is uh that the treatment group contains
all the red hats and all the crown hats
okay maybe this is just one bad
randomization here i'll do another one
but you'll find that treatment contains
all the pointy hats and we only have one
skirt
so independent random assignment it
seems intuitively good but it can lead
to bad covariate uh imbalance especially
when the number of things i'm measuring
is large relative to the number of
people in my trial
okay so you might get frustrated here
and try to get good covariate balance so
a different thing to do is to balance
the two treatment groups so i'm an
optimizer i sat down and i do know that
this has optimal balance on all colors
all hat types and all pant types and the
only randomness i'm going to do now is
flip a coin to see which group gets
treatment and which group gets control
now the good news is i have very
comparable groups um but
you know these covariates what they're
wearing can have nothing to do with what
i'm experimenting i'm about to run
and moreover the very little amount of
randomness one random bit seems to be
not so good
um
and there's you know a question of is
there something else in between that we
can do here
so
a little historical debate uh
fisher
acknowledges and proposes
randomization of treatment assignments
in order to yield unbiased estimators of
the treatment effect
but this problem comes up randomization
can lead to covariate imbalances between
the treatment groups and when asked
about this fisher just says of course
this is him it's not as good a picture
as we had last
time but of course if the experiment had
not been started i would re-randomize
and this is fisher according to cochrane
and cochrane according to ruben so the
story is many times out here
now there are many existing designs i
just want to give you a quick you know
idea of what else is out there
there's blocking and stratified designs
maybe have an equal number of men and
women in both groups
is something that seems good
this type of design only works for a few
binary covariates
there's matching
designs where you pair similar units up
you like match them and then you
randomize within pairs one person gets
treatment one person gets control
so people have argued that matching is
an optimal design but this optimal is
within you know uh
uh amongst oops amongst stratified
designs
and it requires knowledge of the
outcomes and so that's not going to be
too helpful in this context here
and if you're a machine learning
person you know you might know that no
good matching should exist in high
dimensions vectors will be far away so
maybe matching's not the right thing
either
now re-randomization is a type of design
where what you do is you reject
assignments that you deem to be unbap
balanced so lock morgan and ruben argue
that you know a certain formalized
version of this will always improve
precision of your estimators but this is
under a joint leak gaussian assumption
on outcomes and covariance that sort of
hides a lot of the nuance and the
trade-offs that we're going to find in
this talk
and finally leon 2018 study asymptotic
distributions of treatment effect
estimators under re-randomization
designs but the problem is that it's
difficult to interpret what these
um types of rejections would mean in
finite
hemp samples
so what's my opinion on this my opinion
is there's a lot of covariate balancing
designs in the literature that exist but
they leave me asking a few questions
first what is covariate balancing what
do we mean when we say that what are we
trying to do
the second is when should we do it it
seems helpful sometimes it seems harmful
other times we should we should know
when we're trying to do this and once
we've decided these two things how
should we balance kaverit's best
and so in this talk i'd like to give one
uh formal answer not the only but one
answer to questions uh that i've raised
here i want to emphasize there will be
no assumptions on potential outcomes nor
the covariates nor the relationships
between them none of these things are
random
and all these results that i'm going to
show will hold in finite stamps samples
nothing is asymptotic except for a few
illustrations which highlight the finite
sample theory
okay so just the interest of time these
are the questions that we asked we're
going to present a new perspective on
covariate balancing which we call the
balance robustness trade-off
and we're also going to pose a new type
of experimental design the gram schmidt
walk designed for navigating this trade
trade-off
so this is you know motivated by recent
advances in algorithmic discrepancy
theory but that's not something i'm
going to be talking about in this talk
and it's not required to understand what
our contributions are
okay so a little bit of review in the
finite
population potential outcomes framework
there's n experimental units think of
these as participants in a clinical
trial that we denote by integers one to
n
and each unit is assigned to one of two
treatments like drug or placebo which we
are which are denoted zi they take
values in plus or minus one and we
collect them into a big vector z this is
the treatment assignment vector it has
entries in plus or minus one
the experimental design or the design
for short is the distribution of random
treatment assignment vectors this is
known to the experimenter it's chosen by
the ex experimenter and treatment
assignment is the only source of
randomness in the finite
population potential outcomes framework
nothing about the units is random except
which treatment they receive
so what are the outcomes each unit has
two potential outcomes one under
treatment and one under control so we
observe ai if you know i receives
treatment and we observe bi if you know
i receives control
and these are called potential outcomes
because i have the potential to observe
both of them but only one of them ever
is
now these are deterministic values
they're unknown to the experimenter
before the experiment starts
the random observed outcome is as
follows here it's random because our
assignment
of the treatment to the units is random
the experimenter may also have collected
pre-treatment covariates which we
collect in a d-dimensional vector we
denote by x i
and this could encode
this could encode age weight height and
pre-treatment lab test results but again
it's a deterministic quantity
we seek to estimate the average
treatment effect which is simply
the average of the contrast between the
two potential outcomes the one or
treatment and the one under control so
for example this could be the difference
in outcomes under drug versus placebo
averaged over all the participants in
our trial
and this quantity cannot be observed
we're only ever going to see half of
these terms here but it can be well
estimated if we randomize and use uh
a type of estimator
and the one that we're going to use is
the horvis thompson s estimator it's unb
biased
and it's basically just a weighted
comparison between the treatment groups
so you take everyone who's gotten treat
treatment look at their outcomes divide
by the probability they were in the
treatment group and everyone who's in
control take their outcomes by the
probability that they were in the
control group
and the mean squared error of the
horvit's thompson estimator can be
derived as follows
it's equal to one on n squared
times this quadratic form mu transpose
covariance of z mu
where what mu is is it's a n-dimensional
vector
whose entries are the sum of potential
outcomes
and this uh n by n matrix is the
covariance matrix of the treatment
assignment of vector
and i'll skip the proof
so the first contribution of this work
is a new perspective on covariate
balancing namely that there is an
inherent trade-off between covariate
balance and robustness in the
experimental design by robustness i mean
the ability to achieve high precision
estimates of treatment effect for all
unknown outcomes and by covariate
balance what i mean is uh the balance of
covariance between treatment groups and
will show this implies the ability to
achieve increased precision uh for
certain uh outcomes namely those which
are linearly related to the covariance
so a design is robust if the mean square
error is small for all potential
outcomes in some fixed set this is like
a worst case analysis
and the set that i'll be considering
today is potential outcomes with bounded
average magnitude so this is the average
the average of what the magnitude of the
potential outcomes just the squared sum
of the two outcomes here think about m
being a constant but for us it won't
really matter
dilemma that we have says amongst all
designs which assign treatment to each
unit with probability half
the worst case mean squared error over
potential outcomes in this set
is equal to m squared divided by n
squared these are two things you cannot
change this depends on your set this is
the number of samples that you have
but what shows up which depends on the
design is this operator norm here
it's the operator norm of the covariance
of z
and this is our notion of robustness
because it exactly captures what the
worst case mean squared error is
so which designs are the most robust is
a natural question to ask well the
operator norm of this covariance of zed
uh captures the amount of correlation or
dependencies between individual
assignments
and so when there's very little
dependence the operator norm should be
small and we're very robust and indeed
we have a lemma that says the covariance
the operating room is always at most one
and in particular for independent
assignments it's exactly equal to one
so in other words the bernoulli design
with independent assignment is the most
robust in the sense that it minimizes
this worst case mean squared error
so now we introduce a measure of
covariate balance motivated by assumed
linear relationships between the
outcomes and the covariates
so i'm not making this assumption for
the talk i'm just having a hypothetical
thought experiment suppose that there
exists a beta
such that the sum of the outcomes is
exactly equal to this inner product of
beta and the covariant vector x x i
then we can write this this mu vector
this like sum of potential outcomes
as x beta
and now the mean squared error of the
horwitz thompson estimator we can just
plug in x beta for mu
now it's a quadratic form in beta but
the matrix inside has changed
i don't know how to make this small
because it depends on beta and beta is a
linear function that i don't know if i
want to make it small for all beta
i can do the operator norm bound
okay so if if i the main message is that
in order to increase precision when the
covariates are linearly predictive of
the outcomes we should aim to decrease
this operator norm
it's the covariance of x transpose z
now what is x transpose z
it is equal to the difference of within
group sums we call this the sine
discrepancy vector
okay and just to give an alternative
like motivation for it is that this
operator norm encodes balancing of all
linear functions of the covariates
so this term is the difference of within
group sums of covariates in the theta
direction between the two groups
and this is a worst case over all linear
functions so when you're making this
quantity small
this operator norm of the sine
discrepancy vector
that is balancing all possible linear
functions so that's what we're trying to
do
now the balance robustness trade-off is
that there's a fundamental tension
between creating a design which is
robust and which balances covariates so
for instance robustness requires
uncorrelated treatment assignments and
covariate balance that requires
correlation in the treatment assignments
and one insight that we have is that
every design navigates this trade-off in
some uh implicit way
now can we formally define the problem
of navigating this trade-off here
and our
uh formalization is this
for which pairs of sigma x and sigma z
does there exist a distribution on
treatment assignments
satisfying the condition that the
probability that any unit gets treatment
is one half
and we have these two bounds on these
two operator norms remember this is our
robustness one
which we're bounding it by sigma z
squared and this is our covariate
balance one which we're about which
we're bounding by sigma x squared
so the minimal set of sigma z and sigma
x forms the pareto front
tier
uh and one question i want to ask is
well how can we navigate this can we
navigate it with one algorithm
to the exact frontier
for some exact set of covariance that
might be a challenge but we can get sort
of pretty close
um in some kind of
you know worse worst case kind of kind
of way
uh i want to highlight this is a
distributional discrepancy problem here
most discrepancy problems try to find
one assignment that makes
vectors balanced but we're asking for a
distribution over assignments
that has some distributional quantity
here
okay so what are relevant values of
sigma z and sigma x well sigma z takes
values one to n so one is the most
robust everything is independent n is
extremely not robust it's either this
treatment assigned vector or this one
with probability half
on the other hand the balance term that
depends on the covariate vectors
themselves
so relevant you know upper and lower
bounds
uh the first is what happens under
independent assignments most robust i'm
not balancing covariates at all well
that's the operator norm of x x
transpose
which is always at least n divided by d
times the average of the euclidean
squared norms
and the relevant lower bound is without
further assumptions on the covariates
you cannot make this quantity smaller
than the largest uh norm of any of your
covariate vectors and the way i see that
this is true is to imagine one outlier
is orthogonal to all the rest
is there a sign
the qualities are going in the same
direction here on that wall oh yeah so
this is the upground you should have in
your head
but that might be hard to understand and
i'm telling you this upper bound is at
least this amount and this is a lower
bound so that's yeah
but you know roughly speaking the gap
between these two values is at least you
know
roughly speaking is n divided by
t
so there's quite a large gap between
what random assignment would do and what
this hypothetical best we could get
would uh be
and it's i'll say it's empty hard to
sample from a distribution uh for which
this quantity is even like a constant
smaller than this
okay now why should you care about this
distributional discrepancy problem so
that's what we're calling covariate
balance but why does that matter
well here's my answer uh suppose that
the design satisfies problem one then we
get this bound on the precision of the
unadjusted horvitz thompson s estimator
this is a
minimum over this entire quantity here
over all linear functions beta
now you might recognize this as kind of
being a ridge regression except i've hid
some crossing terms let me point out
what these two terms mean
the first one is how well a linear
function beta of the covariates fits the
outcomes
the second is the complexity of that
linear
function
when we call this kind of result
regression by design
so if the design yields that the design
can yield high precision uh
estimates
if the outcomes are well approximated by
a simple linear function and you chose
to balance covariates at least just a
little bit why is that true suppose
there's a beta that makes this term
small that means that there's or
smallish there's some good linear fist
well then you're okay with the
robustness being a little bit bad
because you can
balance the covariates make this term
small and the overall you know term will
be small here
so that's regression by
design
no regression is actually ever conducted
right our estimator is a simple horvitz
thompson estimator we've put all the
regression into the design phase
okay what's the main result
the main result is that we have a design
called the granitic walk design which
solves this problem in the following way
for all fee
in between zero and one we can sample
from a distribution that satisfies the
following the robustness term
is at most one over fee times one and
the covariate balancing term is at most
one over one minus feet
times this thing that i said was the
best you could possibly have
okay so for fee equals one we achieve
the optimal robustness it's just the
bernoulli design
but for phi equals zero we have optimal
covariate balancing in the way that
we've defined it
and for all being between zero one we
interpolate between these two values
here
and i should point out that these are
just bounds
um like as feed goes to one this this
blows up to infinity that's just you
know
a point of the bound
that's not how the algorithm actually
behaves
okay we'll visit the implications for
mean squared error
now let me just give a little bit of
comparison to other designs like does
any other design solve this problem that
i raised i want to answer that question
the answer is no
uh not that i'm aware of in general any
matching will incur the following
balance term so this is the best
achievable
and this is some this is a constant this
is some quantity that depends on n and d
and if d is bigger than three then this
term like blows up
and so in particular like this is just
more evidence of the fact there's no
good matchings in high dimensions so we
cannot get optimal covariate balancing
as we've defined it through matchings
re-randomization is trickier because
it's not so
analytically tractable but we have some
simple like covariates that we wrote out
by hand and we run some simulations and
this is the pareto frontier between
robustness and balance
that rear imagination has so it's kind
of all over the place and it's much
higher than our theoretical bounds which
are in green
uh and the actual performance the
grammation walk design which is in red
okay so i hope to have demonstrated so
far
that
these are well motivated notions of
robustness and covariate balance
and that there is a fundamental tradeoff
between constructing an experimental
design which is robust and moment
balances covariates you cannot have both
things at the same time
so we can formalize this trade-off as a
distributional discrepancy problem and
the solution well the reason why we care
about it is because it has strong
implications for the precision of the
horvis thompson estimator
and i've also hoped to point out the
grand schmidt design is near optimal and
previous designs don't do the same thing
it's not to say this is the best design
you should only ever use
but in the context of robustness and
balance if you care about that
you know this improves on others
so in the last few minutes i want to
talk about how does management walk
design work i'm going to give a very
high level overview
of this
are there any questions before i move on
about what i've said so far we have
enough time yeah just a quick question
about the assumptions
the potential outcomes are approximately
linear
no no no i'm not i must have misspoken
no i'm not so the question was are you
assuming the outcomes are approximately
linear functions of the covariates i am
not assuming that we had a thought
experiment where we said if that was
true i should minimize this operator
norm of the covariance of x transpose z
and that was a good but that could be
not true you know i mean if you balance
covariates and they
have nothing to do with you they have
nothing to do with your outcomes and you
shot yourself in the foot a little bit
and our bound that we gave does reflect
that so no i'm not making assumptions
like that if you did then your answer
would be i'm going to always balance
and so we don't want to do that there is
this trade-off that exists
any other questions yeah so if you feel
the discrepancy is very big calling on
that question
what happened the first service was
actually nearby
um if your coherent balancing term is
big
you're asking what what what what
happens in terms of your mean squared
error
well
let me be clear that we have an upper
bound of the mean squared error and what
happens to the upper bound is that you
know if you try to the outer bound is a
minimum overall beta and if you've not
balanced well
uh
like
that's that regularization term the head
beta has a huge regularization penalty
on it because the covariant balancing
term is very very large
so you'll effectively that will pick out
just beta equals zero
and
like you you know you won't have like
balancing the variance
you know won't get you much
um
we're sorry if you cannot balance yeah
actually let me just go back to this you
cannot balance covariance we need to say
that
so right if if if this was very large
you could not increase the penalty here
if you chose beta equal to zero you
wouldn't incur any of this penalty here
at all
and this would be zero so what you're
getting you're getting um
the two norm of this outcome
times your robustness here
that's what that's like the worst case
that's back to what i said the worst
case mean squared error
robustness is what captures that so if
you just said this is very large you set
beta equal to zero you'll get the worst
case out so
you can't say much beyond the worst case
if you don't balance code variants
i think i'm gonna move on
but you should ask later sorry about
that
okay so how does the arrangement walk
work
the key insight is that
it suffices to balance augmented
covariance vectors
and we'll encode the trade-off in the
definition of these augmented covariate
vectors and we're going to balance these
so how are these defined there are the
concatenation of two vectors here
one is a standard basis vector and the
other is my raw covariant vector
now there's some scaling the scaling
depends on fee that's between zero and
one it's a user-defined parameter to
navigate the balance and robustness
and this max term is a scaling so that
this has a norm approximately one and
this has norm at most one
okay so if p goes to one
then we have these augmented covariant
vectors they look like
orthogonal vectors and balancing those
is just to make things totally
independent
and if b goes to zero we have these
augmented covariant vectors just
resemble the actual raw covariant
by balancing these
we we um achieve the trade-off that
we're trying to get
uh this is what i just said here so the
denominator you have squared norm or
just norm
uh oops that should be just norm thank
you yeah yeah that's that's the typo
there the idea is that
this has norm one this has normally most
one so it puts them on the same scale
um now what's the grand schmidt walk
design it's quite
simple as i'm going to describe it here
you take the covariates and the
parameter construct augmented covariates
call gram schmidt walk with these which
is an algorithm that i haven't said yet
to produce a random assignment and then
i'll put the assignment vector
so now the question is what is the grand
schmidt walk
it's uh an algorithm invented by bin sal
the douche gargan lovett in 2018
for discrepancy theory
we improved the analysis we obtain some
optimal constants then their context is
not important but in this context it uh
very much is
so the algorithm let me give you kind of
a flavor of it or what the goal is the
goal is to produce a random signing so
that the discrepancy vector concentrates
around zero that's what the goal is
and earlier authors show that that doing
so yields a constructive result to
bonchex theorem which was a big open
problem in algorithmic discrepancy
theory
now the approach the algorithm takes is
a relaxed one
so instead of considering signings that
are plus or minus one you'll consider
fractional assignings that can take any
value between negative one and one
and so you'll you'll start at zero this
is right in the middle and you'll
randomly walk until you get a plus or
minus one solution and you'll randomly
walk in a very clever way
so let me show you that here
graduate walk is an algorithm in the
n-dimensional hypercube so this is for n
equals two where i can draw it best
the corners are the vertices of the
hypercube these are the assignments
we're gonna start in the middle at that
z naught equals zero
we're gonna pick an update direction
which is chosen by solving some least
squares problem this is like the well
chosenness that i'm not going to get
into here
and you look and you extend this ray and
you see where does it hit lower
dimensional faces of the hyperkeep and
you randomly select one of these two
points with probability such that an
expectation you don't move at all that
is to say we're going to keep some kind
of martingale property here
and we'll do the same thing
we pick some well chosen step direction
according to these squares
we look uh in the rays and say where do
we hit lower dimensional faces at the
cube
and with some probability we go to them
okay this is a random algorithm so it
could have given me something else this
is just one path that i drew but this is
a totally different path
now the computational efficiency
in the naive case to in the it not
naively do this
it's end of the quarter arithmetic
operations there's n iterations and a
linear system solve
but if you're careful about your linear
system solves you can reduce this down
to n squared d
and uh this martingale property that i
sort of alluded to
and the fact that we started at the zero
vector to sort of can convince you
that the probability of assigning
treatments to any unit is exactly equal
to one half and you can you can modify
this you don't you don't have to have
this you can
modify that
what are the main results the first is
that
under the gram schmidt walk algorithm
and this is something that we
have proved
um
then the signed sum of input vectors
satisfies the following thing it's
concentrated around zero
in the sense
of its second moments here namely that
the operator norm of the covariance
matrix
is at most one
and so as a corollary because of how we
design the augmented covariant vectors
we get out this balance between
robustness
uh this yeah this uh balance between
robustness and balance
so our proof technique is basically to
do gram-schmidt orthogonalization on
randomly ordered vectors this is not
what the algorithm does but it's how the
proof technique works
the original analysis would imply a
multiplicative increase of 40 in both of
these constants here
other results we have
improved mean squared error bound with
better dependence on on uh
uh b here namely that crossing term i
never wrote out we can remove that
crossing term
and asymptotically if you pick phi in
good ways the mean squared error is like
the sum of the residuals of the best
linear fit that's the kind of asymptotic
variance they're going to be getting
under this design with well chosen fee
and a finer understanding of covariate
balancing in different directions is
included in the paper but not in this
talk
okay so in the last minute i want to say
that we also have um
balance in the moment
generating function here namely that in
all direct directions
um we have this is one sub
caution the original authors had 40 here
by using a taylor series approximation
and martin gayle friedman inequality
and once we had this gaussian result we
can lift that back and say this implies
sub gaussian tails on our treatment
effect estimator where instead of having
the variance here we have the upper
bound on the variance which is this
ridge regression by design type of thing
our proof technique is very new and cool
um
this is strong binary sample guarantees
nothing asymptotic here
and
this facilitates construction of
conservative confidence intervals
now i'm going to conclude and say that
we formally defined the balance
robustness trade-off we presented the
grants and walk design for navigating
the trade-off in a near optimal way
there's many more results in the paper
and i want to conclude with three open
problems
the first is how to do this in an online
setting
so if your units come one at a time and
you must assign treatment randomly one
at a time how can you still get this
balanced robustness trade-off is that is
that possible or do you have to incur
log factors here
uh we do not have asymptotic normality
of the horvis thompson estimator under
this design
because there's
sort of very weak but irregular
dependencies months treatment
assignments so that's would you know
this would uh give us tighter confidence
intervals
and lower bounds what are lower bounds
in this pareto frontier that's something
we don't know
so thank you uh for listening to my talk
i'm on the postdoc job market my office
number is this there's the paper i've
implemented this in julia and r so you
can play around with it and that's all i
have to say thank you
[Applause]
thank you very much
can i invite the
other two speakers up to the um stage
and we'll have two chairs
and we can then switch over to the
questions and for those of you
on zoom i will take questions as well i
will watch the chat if you just put out
this one
you